amith is playing a lottery game where he
must pick two numbers from zero to nine
and then one letter out of the 26 letter
english alphabet he may choose the same
number both times
if his ticket matches the two numbers
and one letter drawn in order he wins
the grand prize
and receives ten thousand four hundred
and five dollars
if just his letter matches but one of
both one or both of his numbers do not
match he wins the small prize of one
hundred dollars
under any other outcome he loses and
receives nothing the game costs him five
dollars to play so under any other
outcome he he loses and receives nothing
he has chosen the ticket zero for r so
we're assuming he bought he's paying the
five dollars to play and he picks the
ticket zero for r
so let's say we define
a random variable x
and let's say that this random variable
is the the net profit
the net profit
from playing from playing this this
lottery game
what is the expected
from i i guess we could even say the
expected from the net the the net profit
from playing
4 r so m its particular ticket right
over here so let's just say x is the
random variable it's the net profit from
playing
this ticket what i want to think about
in this video is what is the expected
value of that what is the expected value
of that what is the expected net profit
from playing 0 4 r and i encourage you
to pause the video and think through it
on your own
so let's think about what expected value
is it's the probability of each of those
outcomes times the net profit from from
those outcomes so there's the
probability of the grand prize right
that is let me do that in that red color
so there is the probability of getting
the grand prize
and now what would times his net payoff
from the grand prize what would that be
well he gets 10 405 dollars
but that's not his net payoff his or his
net profit i should say his net profit
is what he gets minus what he paid to
play
so he paid
five dollars to play
so this would be so that's that
so plus
plus the probability of getting the
small price
probability of the small price times the
payoff of the small price
which is going to be 100
or times the net profit i guess if you
get the small price so you get a payoff
of 100 minus you at this pay
minus you have to pay five dollars to
play
and then finally you have the
probability the probability of neither
so you're essentially not winning and
there in that situation what is the net
what is the net profit well in that
situation your net profit is negative
five you paid five dollars and you got
nothing in return so to figure out the
expected value you just have to figure
out these probabilities so what's the
probability of the grand prize we do
that over here probability of a grand
prize
well the probability that he gets the
first letter right
is 1 and 10. there's 10 digits there
probability gets the second letter right
is one and ten these are all independent
and probability gets the letter right
there's 26 equally likely letters that
might be in the actual one so he has a
one in 26 chance of that one as well
so the probability of the grand prize is
1 in what is this 2600
one in 2600 so this is one in 2600. now
what's the probability of getting the
small prize
probability of the small
small price
well let's see
he has a 1 in 26 chance a small prize is
getting the letter right
getting the letter right but not getting
both of the numbers right so he has a 1
and 26 chance of getting the letter
right but this isn't we're not done here
just with the 1 and 26 because he has a
1 in 20 this 1 and 26 this includes all
the scenarios where he gets the letter
right including the scenarios where he
wins the grand prize where he gets the
letter and he gets the two numbers right
so we need to do is we need to subtract
out the situation the probability of
getting the two numbers the getting the
letter and the two numbers right and we
already know what that is it's 1 in 2
600. so it's 1 in 26 minus 1 and 2 600.
the reason why i have to subtract out at
this 2600 is is just one here's a 1 and
26 chance of getting this letter right
so that includes that includes the
scenario where he gets everything where
he gets everything right but the small
prize is only where you get the letter
and one or none of these if you get both
of these then you're in the grand prize
case so you essentially have to subtract
out the probability that you won the
grand prize and you got all three of
them to figure out the probability of
the small prize
now what's the probability of
essentially losing
the probability of neither
well it's it's just kind of you know
that's everything else so if it would be
minus these probabilities right over
here so it would be one minus the
probability of the small prize
probability of the small
minus the probability of the grand these
are the possible outcomes so they have
to add up to one or a hundred percent
so this is one minus probability small
minus
minus probability of large minus
probability of
large or i said not a grand prize
grand
grand prize so let's fill this in so the
probability of the small one
this right over here i'm using that red
too much this right over here is 1 and
26 minus 1 and 2 600
1 in 2600 and then this right over here
is one
minus the small which is one
in twenty six minus one and twenty six
hundred
minus one and twenty six hundred
minus one in
600 and this simplifies to let's see
this is 1 minus 1 over 26
plus 1 in
plus or minus
1 in 2600
these cancel and you're left with 1
minus 1 and 1 and 26. now why does that
make why does this make sense well the
way you lose the way you get nothing is
if you get the letter wrong
so
if you get you have a 1 and 26 chance of
getting the letter right and then you're
going to be in one of these two
categories or you have a 1 minus 126
which is equal to 25 out of 26 you have
a 25 and 25 26 chance of getting the
letter wrong in which case you get
nothing in which case you completely
lose so let's just kick our calculator
out and calculate this and we'll round
to the to the nearest we'll round to the
nearest penny here
so let's see
it is going to be one twenty six hundred
so one
divided by twenty six hundred
times let's see ten thousand four five
minus five is going to be ten thousand
four hundred
times ten thousand four 400 that's your
net profit when you win the grand prize
and then you're going to have plus
1 divided by 26
minus
1 divided by 2600
times
your your net profit for the small price
is 100 minus 5 which is 95
and then finally
plus
25 26
so 25
divided by 26 actually i'll put
parentheses around here just to make it
consistent so 25 divided by 26
times that net payoff when you get
nothing well you have to pay out five
dollars and you've got nothing in return
times negative five
actually i don't know if it's going to
recognize that as time so i'll just
write times
times negative five and let me delete
that
and we deserve a drum roll now we get a
expected net profit of playing as
two dollars and
two dollars and 81 cents if we round up
to the nearest penny so this is all
going to be equal to
two dollars and 81 cents
and so this is actually
a very unusual lottery game where you
have an ex a positive expected net
profit as a player usually the person
operating the lottery the state who or
the casino whoever it is they're the
ones who have the expected net profit
and then the player has the expected net
loss but this actually would make
rational sense to play which most which
is not the case with most lottery games
that if by playing you actually expect a
2.81
net profit